CER Kings get the face off Anderson
shoots it pinballs around backhander
and that goes off a Blue's player
and off the glass that was thef
faier in there number 78 BL don't
clear it and the captain Kopitar
in front they score Kee with a rocket can
he shoot it his 17th of the year it's one
nothing this is Jake neighbors right along
the wall here he gets himself in a little
bit of a Battle Turns the puck over and falls
down unfortunately and H kopar with a lot of
time here and kmy drives right to where
he should right to the middle of the ice
not much chance there if any for Joel Hur
as kempe who's got an absolute bomb he is
out of Wisconsin comes in front now back to
the line gabov and a shot off the shoulder
of hord Center another shot and it's saved by
hoper there on turock and now kyou for Thomas
plays it back to a wide openen Paro and then
Kyu working against England has some room here
in front for lety he shoots he scores lety with
a bomb and the blows have tied the game at one
yep we just finished talking about all that the
blues do a great job of low to high high back
down low Jordan Kyu sees Nick lety changes the
shot Lane just suddenly by dragging that puck
here look at this drags it makes no mistake he's
looking up the whole time shoots it over the shot
blocker's leg and by David rck alexandr battles
low now Philip Doo a good two-way Center former
first rounder by Chicago played in Montreal kept
in by Ley lety shoots it big rebound another shot
by walker and a save by rid neighbors now Castle
right in fires it on goal and a save there by rid
and kept Alive by the blues here's neighbors
wide open right in front neighbors backhander
and a save by R this here late this here in
the offensive zone Castle joining the attack
another defense opportunity and then look at
Jake neighbors finds himself down low waiting
wait then realizes he can take it to the net and
now Kopitar deep in his own in and the Slovenian
to Center ice now for Kee Kee for kopar back
in front and a great save by huler on Mikey
Anderson who had worked in get it there just
didn't didn't click for the goal that time now
good entry by the blues here is Hayes for KR out
High to Shen waiting shoots it and that goes up
high and off the BL treding to go High glove there
and the Kings come back Anderson Dolan for Lewis
and a save rebound they score shorthanded goal I
think Anderson DOL it in there and the Kings lead
2-1 but see the effort there and then the
followup and then three kings players Off
to the Races here Bren Shen trying to help
out defensively Lewis is the key at it all
here though cuz he drives to the net with
it carries the momentum to the blue paint
and Anderson Dolan is the benefactor of that
loose Puck pass back to the line and broken
up by Deno BL get out now they get back in
with B Davis out the line now for perunovic
and he walks in in front B davit CH and he scores
another Power Play goal B davic and it's two to
two for his teammates to get back on
side and then watch him walk it here
and then he opens up the hips that forces
the player to respect the pass up high it
allows perunovich to get further down the
wall and then Pavo bvic finds that quiet
area right in the middle of the diamond
who's almost scored a goal there off the
rush which is not easy to do in the power play
now Thomas to the goal line Neighbors in front
pass and that was broken up in 10 and for B
davage kyou and turkot fight for it Kee back
check by bu davich and now brunovich Quick
Pass for Kyu to the middle bu davish for
Thomas what a pass another pass Kyu right down
Broadway he scores cyu great passing that was
sick passes it over to Thomas little deflection
there by perunovich I believe who just sort of
touches it yes what a play by Scott perunovic
just redirect it to Jordan car who makes no
mistake but puts it back to perunovic and he waits
now on to kyou he goes for a half lap kovich gets
it goal line Thomas on goal and it's saved by
rck well with that duo out there of K and Kar
they're big guys they skate well they got good
reach they're tough to get around here sometimes
and the BL don't get in look out Kings come back
here's Moore short-handed and a great save by Hur
on Trevor Moore who has 21 goals on the year and
remember that's saved by hord who had lost his
stick and the Kings to Center ice and Anderson
is out of the box one shot by St Louis on the
power fight now do shoots and he scores and do
with a great shot and the Kings tie the game at
three now certainly not the way that
you'd like to end the second period
had short-handed offensive opportunities
but this year is right after the penalty
expires Deno gets to the middle of
the ice and you hear that ping in
the background there goes Po and in but
again got to tighten up a little bit he
gets his 10th goal of the year and he ties it
at 1844 now the king's in again and a save by
hoer right there pinpoint
Precision getting that one on
goal and off the face off Alexandro off comes
in front and a backhander oh and a good save by
rck as that scrambled face off on the outside for
fala on the given goal broken up by Paro and then
Walker Oh his pass picked off by Trevor from war
Kings get it and a shot right on rebound oh what a
save by Hur on the rebound on fiala his best stop
today and Joel hfer with a great save right there
a sunru big save by Joel Hofer look at that gets
AC KR again now B dich that's by gabov around the
outside now B Dage once again in front Thomas
what a save by Ric on Robert Thomas best save
today Seattle Shen got the winner in Vancouver
on Wednesday and the blues do it again for the
third straight time and now Kyu hands it back
to Thomas skates away from copar here he comes
Thomas to the front and a save by R what a move
there by Robert Thomas walking right around kopar
who won two suky trophies as the best defensive
forward not easy to do and now Kopitar plays it
back and then it's Den for more quickly into
the zone now for den and he waits knocked down
in front by B davage Shen behind the defense
gets it here he comes Shen CH the scars Shan
again this is getting
crazy pick it up here is the puck comes up
the wall and brayen Shen just comes in on
the left wing you can tell he's loading
up that shot he's having a look rck must
have just lowered his hand a little bit and the
captain puts it top shelf just a fantastic shot
glove side off the post and end he likes that
glove side same as in Vancouver the other night